for russian soldiers heading for the
front lines in ukraine there's a chance
for confession and communion
it's often their first the military
chaplain says this is an air defense
crew in ukraine taking part in what
russia calls its special military
operation the operations architect now
accuses the west of trying to cancel
russian culture in retaliation
tchaikovsky shostakovich
are being removed from concert programs
russian writers and their books are
being banned as well last time we saw
such massive destruction of unsuitable
literature was almost 90 years ago in
nazi germany we remember very well the
footage of books being burned
putin says the war in ukraine is about
what he calls denazifying the country
it was a theme his foreign minister
pursued in reference to europe's tactics
towards russia
they declared a real hybrid war
total war
this term used by nazi germany is now
used by many european politicians when
they say what they want to do with the
russian federation
russia faces further isolation if the
u.s and its allies succeed in expelling
moscow from the g20 group of major
economies
but the kremlin says
nothing terrible will happen if it's
kicked out
bernard smith al jazeera moscow